cause he loved here's your Mormon and go
as far as it's so sad to lose you why
was it like shooting your death scene
well as these are death scenes are
always so funny you know and there's
quite a lot of nervous laughter around
you know but yeah it was it was a
shocking but they wanted to make it as
shocking as possible you know and as
surprising as possible and I think that
worked and so it's really pleased it's a
great way to go out and he certainly
fought to the end didn't even he gave
rest a bit back didn't it oh absolutely
yeah that the old beer took a lot of
killing of course you've seen the death
of rasped this season he's gone what do
you think about that yeah yeah I think
that's one of the qualities of Game of
Thrones that it you know it executes
people all over the place good bad and
indifferent you know and I think that's
what keeps one of the reasons it keeps
its audience you know it just keeps
everyone on the edge what's what's gonna
happen and we've also lost one of our
biggest villains this season as well in
Joffrey Baratheon you died his own
wedding what did you think about well
that's George Martin for you you know if
you haven't read the books you're in for
big shocks you know I think he's such an
amazing writer you know and twists and
turns and throws things in music
astonishing if your scenes which are the
ones you enjoyed the most filming which
one's kind of stick in your memory the
one scene that really sticks in my
memory is I think I might be in season
two with Jon Snow where I gave him the
The Wolf said swords and there was a
there was a really nice subtext there of
you know Mormont losing his son to the
other side and him seeing something in
Jon Snow that he wanted to pass on
I really we both cared and I both
enjoyed that seem tremendously
of course you mentioned your son there
jorah mormont he's played by Ian glass
would you have high hopes for him you
never know but I just loved watching he
and he's a fabulous actor yeah very
proud because playing my son
unfortunately djor didn't have the
qualities that you need to survive in
Game of Thrones it was so sad to see it
go but if you had to say what you need
to kind of stay alive and thrive in the
Game of Thrones world what do you think
those qualities are well I think Mormont
died because he was the kind of man he
was and he was very unusual in the whole
the whole panoply of characters in that
he was a very straightforward man he had
no ulterior motives all he did was
protect the wall and protect everyone
inside it and so obviously and at some
point he had to go but I think you have
to have a certain Machiavellian either
you have to have a Machiavellian
instincts about how to survive or you're
like more months and hopefully Jon Snow
who has a innate decency do you think
the Nights Watch the Castle black is now
that they've lost you I think a true
leader will emerge you know come as the
time come as the man you could have been
any other character in the show apart
from Mormon who would you like to have
been I think if I was a younger man to
play John Snow would be great you know I
think that's a pretty cool part to play
and he would you like to finally see on
that road at the end of the day again
only one guy Jon Snow
absolutely absolutely he'd be the best
he was and it may happen that may happen
you never know it's been lovely talking
to you thanks every time it's been a
great pleasure thank you
you